Hello everybody.
I'm Austin, I'm here from Metronome,
and we're here to tell you why use space building must
be treated as infrastructure.
So this is actually our first, uh,
AWS reinvent that I've been to and
can be more proud to be here.
Um, we have folks from across the industry,
um,
companies like,
uh, Salesforce that invented SAS to modern,
uh, startups like OpenAI and Anthropic,
defining the future of what computing is,
so. I'm
Austin. I'm a solutions engineer here at
Metronome, so I've helped, uh.
Develop and land and expand
some of our uh largest clients
as well as our startup program
uh which I'll tell you more about towards the end of this
presentation.
So
Metronome does support some of the largest names
in AI as well as usage-based
uh software
today. So those are names that you might have
heard of like OpenAI and Confluent,
uh, as well as Anthropic, Nvidia, Lang Chain.
It's been pretty fun walking around the expo floor
this week and seeing a lot of the logos,
uh, that we've helped support,
grow, and grown with over the past several years.
So why must
Usage based billing, modernization
be infrastructure in this modern age.
I think we're all familiar with the previous eras of
software you sell a license, you
kind of forget,
and they use as much or as little
of that service as you provide.
Then we move this access,
uh, subscription consumption seats, a
little bit more of this value match, but as
you can see, let's try out the laser clicker
that's fun.
Uh, we are here at the nexus of
this new era, this
agentic outcome, workflows,
actions, hybrid, you name
it, we are seeing new pricing
models be invented
nearly.
I wouldn't say every day, but it's it's pretty common,
and they're all coming into Metronome and discussing
with us about how
to meet the value of their product
with their end customers, and it's also
safe to say
that Metronome is here and has been
here to support these pricing models,
things that we like to call hybrid, which
are really exciting. So as companies
transition from pure seats
to seats with allocations, trying
to understand and meet that value with their end
customers while also understanding.
That the underlying cost structure of their
service is changing.
LLMs are obviously,
uh, pure usage, and so when you
actually use them, you're burning down on
something you're incurring costs. It's very difficult
to match that towards a see of subscription,
so we're moving in this new age where,
as I'm sure you're seeing from the entire expo floor,
everybody's talking about agentic pricing.
It's very difficult to just slap on that
to a subscription and say that you're done.
Monetization is now real time. So
in the past billing used to be this
kind of
slow humdrum service.
You'd batch processes, you give your customers
a monthly invoice. They're all backward
looking. You have to
update things in spreadsheets. It's all kind of
relegated to the back office. Finance
doesn't really
care or talk to anybody else. It's really about
collecting bills at the end of the month and those subscriptions
are really what they are.
They're really detached from the product experience and
detached from that value that we're talking about.
Monetization now is real time
things like, uh, your
in moment workflows and notification systems,
gating entitlement, as well as making it
core to the product experience.
Everybody here on this expo floor
can certainly tell you that. If you go and
use chat DBT, you're interacting with a thing
called tokens. Now, can everybody describe what a
token is? I'm not sure. Some days
I don't know,
but it is core towards the usage of these
products. It is a strategic growth lever
as you're connecting
the the experience with your customers
to the end state of actually using the
product. So
monetization is the infrastructure, right?
It is the continuous flywheel of
developing your product and
continuing to iterate and match with your
customers. So
Metronome, uh, in particular
does this through what we call our events. These
are business events, any sort of transaction
that might incur costs that might incur usage,
that might change the utilization
of your product. These are things like an API
call. I keep talking about LLMs.
Inferences being made, servers spun up, spun
down, continuous heartbeats while
a service lives live. These are all
things that have
we're very familiar with and have been around for years, but
actually attributed to them in real time and
doing things like gating off access,
letting customers know they're going into overages,
or even just from a go to market perspective, letting
them know, hey, you've hit. 90% of your
pre-commit, you might want to engage in an upsell.
These are things that we think are critical and they can't just be
done on even a daily basis
or even worse, a monthly basis. These have to be real
time. These are engagements that are pretty critical
that we're all are starting to become very deeply
familiar with whenever you, uh,
hit a little bit too much send on cloud code
and it runs for a little bit too far.
That's the kind of real-time product
experience that you need and that's why
this is an infrastructure problem. This isn't just
something that happens on the back office anymore.
In invoices and revenue data
have to be understood in real time, and
this is also where Metronome starts to sit.
The usage aggregation, the invoice computation
happens on every single event.
It is generating a new invoice. It's how
we think about these sorts of problems.
So why is this hard?
Why is Metronome even around? User space billing
is not some novel concept. We
didn't invent it. We just seem to be getting it
right. That's because in the
past transactional observability
was a pick two problem. You had correctness,
low latency, and high availability, and everybody
just kind of chose to, and we're like it's
good enough.
But again this is extremely difficult. Correctness
on its own for financial services, you would, you
need to make sure that every single cent is attributed
and matched. You need to make sure that you're ready
for your audits as you go
continuing to be, let's say, a public company
and confluent or you're a startup and making sure
that, uh,
you actually pass an audit so you can raise that next
round of funding.
Events also may arrive out of order. These
things need to be burned down on the actual attribution
of that time stamp that you're sending in the metronome.
This can't just be a a hey, we'll receive it eventually
and it gets attributed.
Correctness is key towards a, a
billing platform.
Low latency. This is again what we keep talking
about that real-time service alerts
for entitlement gating and fraud detection.
We're moving towards these usage
platforms that are customers,
uh, PLG oriented
so customers have immediate access, but as a
business. Provider,
you don't necessarily trust somebody who might just be signing
up for your service. Now you might give them a free trial credit,
but the difference between that and actually
making sure that you're not running and incurring bad
debt while also growing your business is essential.
Your customers are also starting to expect real-time
information. There are plenty of uh
platforms that we're all very familiar with that
maybe give you a 24 hour update after
usage that can't be the same thing for
a PLG style consumer
oriented product. You need to understand in real
time your burndown is and also if you're talking
about a finance team, they need to understand
across all sorts of customer, all sorts of
users where they're actually at month
to month.
And then that high availability, this is
because it's infrastructure because it lives at the core
of this product,
you need to have extremely high availability.
Billing can never go down. Your product
might be able to go down,
but billing has to be
available, has to be ready to be up
at every single moment. Those dashboards
that power all sorts of these things have to
be extremely available so you can understand
where your clients are at.
Again, why is metronome
what we are?
Because we got all three.
The infrastructure principles applied to monetization
are these 4.
It has to be scalable. It has to be modular. It has
to be, you have to be able to orchestrate things and it has
to be extensible as your company
and your customer base grows and as you iterate.
Nobody actually gets pricing right on the first go,
so that means that every single. One of these pieces
of this puzzle have to be extensible, have
to be scalable. You have to be able to change
things. You have to be able to think ahead as well as
potentially backdate things and extend
the platform
as your company grows and you start to build more
pieces of your billing stack.
Scalability for one, real-time
information on ingest that's invoice computation
as I talked about during usage.
Surges can happen,
but you need to be able to like ingest
in real time,
not fall over.
OpenAI, as I'm sure you can imagine, scaling
up and scaling down
all in um a very flexible
fashion.
Modularity, this is really where Metronome
got things right over the past couple of years,
decoupling every single piece of
your, your billing model so you
can do things like
having extremely nuanced customer
contracts for your largest customers who are really
good negotiators and then the opposite. Side
of things when you have a PLG segment
that is completely separate but also
the same products at their core, being able
to roll out those pricing changes while
not being able to do things like migrations
we like to say that migrations are a dirty word at at
Metronome. We don't do them, everything is
updated in real time.
And that orchestration that is things like
having those invoices be sent off to
your actual payment provider, having
those dashboards, uh, inform
your customers, those spend alerts
you can have things like a
90% threshold warning, let customers
go into arrears, but still gate them off when they
hit 150%. These are becoming core
product experiences that are essential
and, uh, deeply entrenched in your billing.
As well as those credit ledgers, you need to
understand at the end of the day for revenue recognition
purposes for burn down purposes
where things are actually going.
And that extensibility
Metronome sits at the heart of your entire modernization.
So again we talked about those usage events, those
transactions that are coming in, they're feeding
into this platform that has that real-time
meeting and rating pricing and packaging, which
is extensible and flexible,
as well as the contract life cycle management,
knowing what. When your customers are gonna
be ending their contract,
when to
engage with them again on a sales motion,
when to move them to a free trial, when to
move them to an arrears contract, and
then from there is what you get on the bottom
and the right hand side of this graph.
So it is things like,
let's make sure I don't hit the wrong button, your
CRM as well as your billing portal and all
the data lakes so that your team
can understand extremely deeply where
your finances are at, where your customers are at.
Evaluate,
understand, analyze, and iterate on your pricing
and packaging, as well as
this right-hand side where all the money actually
goes. That's what we
at the end of the day actually care about is that while we're
actually doing a consumption-based business, we need to
make sure that we're collecting the invoices for
our customers. It isn't just for the love of the
game. It is actually we need to make sure that our business
is healthy
and that those invoices be sent somewhere.
And of course AWS Marketplaces,
Metronome also sits and provides for them,
as well as a little company called Stripe.
So you have to be prepared for this velocity of AI.
AI is not just the buzzword
anymore, it's the businesses that we all operate in.
Companies like uh are are
testing their pricing model. They're making iterations,
uh, they, you know, OpenAI in particular
made 10+ pricing changes in the past
12 months.
You know, somebody might wake up and decide that they
want to compete on a different model and they drop the price.
They do that through Metronome as
well as 85% of. Software companies are adopting
usage based pricing.
It might not be core and essential towards their pricing
model, but it might be some
hybrid aspect as they are rolling
out things like
an agent on top of their platform
or integrating LLMs into the product
experience. These are becoming
essential towards the new era of software.
So modernization engineers, this is a new title
that we're seeing actually on uh
hiring pages,
why they should demand all these aspects
out of their platform.
Can your service process millions of events
in real time? Can you handle that PLG
scale that is, uh,
the new
way to grow your business isn't just a like
marketing scheme. It is actually how you. Mature
customers, early adopters into
enterprise customers, kind of stay up with
everything, right? What we talked about that that billing
needs to be essential and needs to always be available.
Can you deploy those pricing changes without real
deploys,
without migrations? Can you do a few clicks
from somebody who is not an engineer?
Can you set this pipeline up to be
completely removed and let RevOps then do. Things
like pricing changes, pricing experiments
in your platform,
and can finance and product share one source
of truth. This isn't just an engineering
problem. This is a finance problem. This is a bizopps
problem, but it is something that can be solved
by engineers evaluating the proper
tool that will take you from today
through the end state of
potentially this entire, uh, AI
era. And
again, Metronome powers this modernization
infrastructure, so we sit at this
at the center of this with real-time invoice compute
and uh a modular pricing
model so we can
create, iterate, roll through pricing
changes and
issue out those usage statements and invoicing
data.
Obviously OpenAI is pretty essential
towards our business and we have a pretty good case study
for them. It's on our website if you want to read more,
but Metronome is at the heart of
how, uh, OpenAI joined. We actually
like to say that when OpenAI joined us, we got the name
wrong. There were some random little research lab we called
them OpenAPI.
They're now a little bit more, uh, relevant towards
our, our day to day lives. They're adding new
LLMs every day.
They are deploying to millions of users in
real time. They're making pricing
updates that are not,
you know, months.
Discussions,
committees, these are done with finance
and they're matching the value while understanding
the analytics that are coming out of Metronome and
they have ultra efficient billing operations.
So, a little exciting thing that we're doing here
at Reinvent. If you want to come by our booth
and sign up to claim $1 million in
customer billing credits,
you may have to go through another demo, you may not,
but we will get you set up and live and
uh you can start using Metronome today,
playing around, kicking in the tires and get
again a million dollars worth of customer
billing credits with Metronome.
Our booth is right over there, somewhere near
Silla Cribble-ish.
There's a number on there, but nobody's actually looking those up.
Thank you. Again, come see us at our booth.